blooming june in london's queue gardens
but now boris johnson has plotted the
way ahead on his covet road map
freedom day in england on june the 21st
is to be delayed for four weeks
obviously i'd like things just to keep
opening up more and more
but i think it really depends on whether
things are
safe or not to do so it's a tricky one i
don't
envy the job of the scientists to to
call it and the politicians to make the
decision
the delay is the result of a third wave
of covert infections
which has persuaded the government to
wait until more people have been
vaccinated
and crucially more people have had a
second jab
there are still two million people over
the age of 50
who haven't been vaccinated and just a
month's breathing space would give us
the opportunity
not only to fully jab more people
including
all the folk who are over 40 but also
give
time for the immune response to kick in
besides the four-week delay until july
the 19th
the pm is expected to announce rules on
masks and working from home guidance
remain
table service only in pubs stays and no
change for theaters but the limit of 30
wedding guests
will be relaxed but many tory mps view
the delay in ending england's lockdown
with alarm
i can understand why there is a
significant degree of caution
but what i would very much like to hear
are the
objective measures that the government
will be looking at
which will enable them to unlock fully
at some time in the coming weeks
and in the vaccine minister nadim
zahawi's stratford-on-avon constituency
there are fears for the hospitality
trade we've been promised june 21st
um i mean it's looking like maybe it's
gonna be pushed back
uh two weeks or four weeks um i mean
every little bit that's
an extra payment an extra rate that
they're gonna need to pay and kind of
and those kind of
um those things need to be addressed so
much for a sunny outlook for the economy
there could be storm clouds ahead john
craig
sky news